en el vídeo pasado vimos corporaciones y
responsabilidad limitada y quizás te
estés preguntando bueno y fue todo justo
porque si gabe hubiera sido dueña del
taxi el jugador hubiera recibido el
millón por el cual la demandó entonces
porque su carrera fue arruinada por el
accidente entonces recordemos que esta
chica lo que hizo fue armar una
corporación y puso los activos de la
compañía de transporte en la corporación
entonces limitó su responsabilidad así
que el jugador solamente pudo obtener
900 mil pesos y la corporación fue a
bancarrota obviamente pero la obligación
de gabi se redujo se redujo la
contribución de la corporación entonces
quizás tú digas bueno qué onda la vida
del jugador fue arruinada y no puede ser
compensado por su vida que fueron nada y
gabi bueno muy agusto tiene dinero
debería pagarle porque tiene dinero para
pagarle quizás parezca que es una manera
injusta que las corporaciones una manera
injusta para que las personas con mucho
dinero protejan sus bienes y de hecho a
tal grado es verdad pero esto en
realidad es un balance que la sociedad
debe tomar por conveniencia a la elige
entonces bueno aquí sí es cierto que en
cierto modo exagera el panorama porque
plantea una historia donde de una manera
injusta para el jugador porque él
solamente va a obtener 900 mil pesos por
algo que arruinó su carrera y más aún
arruinó su forma de vida y gabi quizás
diga bueno si las corporaciones
funcionan para limitar la
responsabilidad para personas como yo
que es algo bastante cómodo pero por
otro lado gabino hubiera iniciado esta
compañía de transportes y las
corporaciones no tuvieran esa
responsabilidad limitada es algo
bastante cómodo para personas y quizás
gabi tenían todos estos activos y como
puedes ver rebasan ese millón ella tenía
para pagarle al jugador y si las
corporaciones no tuvieran
responsabilidad limitada ella no hubiera
iniciado su compañía de transporte
porque para empezar estos 800 mil pesos
para arriesgar 800 mil pesos de un taxi
por el resto del imperio bueno no tiene
mucho sentido no suena lógico porque
cuánto podría dar un taxi comparado con
lo que ya tenía así que si no existiera
la responsabilidad limitada no
existirían las corporaciones para
empezar
otra cosa que me podría decir es miren
chicos bueno quien sea que inicie un
negocio de taxis el cual podría iniciar
con supongamos que 90 mil 80 mil pesos
por hay más o menos 100 mil tal vez
todos estos negocios tienen el mismo el
mismo riesgo
y quien tenga un taxi la ciudad va a
ganar más o menos lo mismo todo mundo
que tenga taxis ganará lo más o menos lo
mismo entonces se argumentará que será
injusto que haya ciertas desventajas
porque quizás no se ha dicho por acá
racing days y por acá solamente tenga un
taxi más la licencia y supongamos que
800 mil pesos y el seguro el seguro que
son 100 mil pesos supongamos entonces
gabi argumentar a lo siguiente ella dirá
bueno y qué tal si de y si yo podemos
abrir el mismo negocio de transporte y
si no hubieran las corporaciones y gabi
tuviera que ser dueña de de los activos
de la compañía de forma de una forma
directa entonces ser dueña del taxi más
su licencia dhabi tendría la mayor
desventaja porque si gavi aunque gane en
el mismo dinero de ladies y entonces si
no hubieran las corporaciones gabi tiene
todos estos activos todos esos activos
que ya tiene están en riesgo están en
total riesgo entonces quizás eso haga
que gaby obtenga una mayor póliza
entonces en lugar de 100.000 en lugar de
100 y supongamos que una de un millón y
quizás están está cueste un poco más
digamos que cuesta 180 mil por obtener
esa póliza y viendo esto de una manera
para proteger sus activos no tener una
corporación la perjudica el costo en su
negocio sería mayor sólo porque tiene
todos estos bienes entonces diría bueno
esto no es justo para mí porque otra vez
sería una razón por la cual alguien con
activos estaría menos inclinado para
iniciar un negocio y otra cosa que
argumentaría gabi sería que a cambio por
responsabilidad limitada también tendría
doble tributación que es un término que
quizás escuches seguido tal vez puede
que pueda entonces escucharás sobre la
doble
doble tributación que no necesariamente
ocurre pero si una corporación es grande
entonces lo más seguro es que la doble
tributación ocurrirá y la idea detrás de
la doble tributación la cual no es
verdadera para todas las corporaciones
de hecho marcar en las diferencias la
doble tributación
ocurre en las llamadas corporaciones de
corps en pero no sucede en las corp s
corp s ni en las de rl que es que es
corporación de responsabilidad limitada
o en la sele s que es sociedad limitada
ni en la s de rl que sociedad de
responsabilidad limitada a ninguna de
estas aplica y lo que sucede en la doble
tributación es que supongamos vamos a
poner un ejemplo digamos que tenemos
aquí a una corporación se estresa corp
se y digamos que tiene una ganancia de
10 mil pesos 10.000 pesos en ganancias
de un año dado ajá así que esta
corporación es tratada como una entidad
legal como una persona de hecho lo vi en
la definición que puse de corporación en
el vídeo pasado y entonces por lo tanto
como es tratado como una persona se le
cobran impuestos se le cobran digamos
que el 30 por ciento de impuestos él da
30 por ciento de impuestos así que esta
corporación para 30 por ciento de
impuestos es decir que vendrán pagando
eso de tres mil pesos en impuestos y
aquí dejaré claro una cosa esto de aquí
estos diez mil son pre impuestos pre
impuestos así que pagan al gobierno 30
por ciento treinta por ciento y le
quedan entonces siete mil pesos netos en
ganancia y luego lo que sigue es
dividirlo entre la sociedad de la
corporación dividirlo entre la sociedad
de la corporación no sé si se me
entendió ok lo divide entre los
accionistas los accionistas y digamos
por simplicidad que solamente hay un
accionista para no hacer las cosas tan
tan complicada solamente un accionista y
este amigo accionista está recibiendo
siete mil pesos de ingreso basado en que
él es el dueño de la corporación
entonces él tendrá que pagar impuestos
nuevamente y digamos lo pongo bueno lo
voy a poner de esta otra manera lo pongo
así supongamos que su tasa de impuestos
marginal su tasa de impuestos marginal
es de 30 por ciento otro 30 por ciento y
30 por ciento de 7.000 serían dos mil
cien pesos dos mil cien pesos que el
pagar en impuestos basado en el ingreso
neto de su parte que lo obtiene de la
corporación ce y bueno quiero ser
bastante cuidadosa aquí no entraré en
detalles pero si ser cuidadosa porque a
los accionistas a veces se les puede
cobrar impuestos de una manera distinta
pero por simplicidad yo aquí dije 30 por
ciento puede ser más o puede ser menos
pero esta es la idea general de doble
tributación a la corporación se le ve
como una entidad legal que paga
impuestos y después de pagar impuestos
le da las ganancias netas a los
accionistas y estos accionistas deben
pagar impuestos nuevamente y de esto se
trata la doble tributación y muchos
dirán bueno oye pero esto es claramente
injusto porque pagan impuestos dobles
por un mismo dinero y alguien dirá bueno
tú estás obteniendo toda esta
responsabilidad limitada si no quieres
pagar doble impuestos pues simplemente
no pongas una corporación y acepta toda
esta toda esta responsabilidad que
conlleva no tener una corporación y debo
ser clara esto aplica mayormente a
corporaciones grandes si tú quieres la
responsabilidad limitada y no quieres
hacer esta doble tributación cualquiera
de esas opciones aquí está disponible
esto es accesible para compañías menos
complicadas entonces por ejemplo la
corte ese aquí se tiene cantidad
limitada de accionistas la cr l son
estas no duran por siempre por ejemplo
si uno de los accionistas muere si uno
fallece o se declara bancarrota entonces
termina
y limitaciones pero se obtienen
beneficios de responsabilidad limitada
responsabilidad limitada y los
beneficios se los llevan los accionistas
sin pagar primero los impuestos por
tanto tienen tributación simple
tributación simple y bueno ya con esto
sigamos con el asunto de si es o no
justo entonces si gavi fue inteligente
cuando inició esta compañía
probablemente eligió una corporación con
responsabilidad limitada o una core pc o
algo así por el estilo que no tenga que
pagar la doble tributación y aún así
también no pagarle evadir pagarle al
jugador su millón porque lo que tenga la
corporación es lo que obtiene el jugador
recordemos eso lo vemos en el vídeo
pasado pero digamos que el servicio de
transporte se engrandece entonces en
este caso se debe convertir a una corp
ese entonces gabi tendrá que hacer todo
esto de la doble tributación pero es
interesante pensarlo en si es justo
tener algo así por el lado pro de las
corporaciones
tenemos que alentar alentar al espíritu
empresarial a jal o alentar las personas
no se preocuparan tanto por perder
bienes entonces nivela la situación y
hay reglas reglas de tener un cierto una
cierta cantidad de dinero para poder
iniciar una corporación y también una
cierta cantidad de dinero en el seguro
sino la corte puede ir detrás de algunos
de los bienes del dueño pero si se
mantiene en una una manera capitalizada
bien no pasará a mayores y bueno es por
un lado ahora por el otro lado tenemos
esta doble tributación que al menos para
corporaciones grandes como por ejemplo
no sé a ver qué se te ocurre aunque
google microsoft
etcétera ellos si pagan una cuota la
cual es esta doble tributación y estas
corporaciones pequeñas tienen
tributación simple y responsabilidad
limitada